the FBI is offering a reward of up to
$25,000 for information leading to an
arrest following the death of a Border
Patrol agent Roja Leo Martinez died in
Texas Sunday David Begg knows outside
the hospital in El Paso where Martinez
died and a second agent is being treated
David good morning good morning that
second agent is in critical but stable
condition here at University Medical
Center in El Paso you know the National
Border Patrol Council the Union for
Border Patrol agents has said these two
agents were attacked and they were
attacked with rocks but no other agency
has said that including the FBI which is
investigating the number of possible
scenarios the FBI special agent in
charge of this investigation
Emerson Bowie says finding out exactly
what happened to Rogelio Martinez and
his partner is now the most important
investigation for the FBI is El Paso
Division the 36 year old Border Patrol
agents death is being treated as a
potential assault on a federal officer
why I call it a potential assault and
not an assault we call it potential
because we do not have the full picture
yet as to what transpired but once we
get closer to that then we'll be able to
present those facts the agents were
found around 11:20 Saturday night in a
culvert next to interstate 10 right
outside the town of Van Horne both men
had broken bones and severe head trauma
a law enforcement source tells CBS News
agent Martinez radioed in earlier that
night that he was getting out of his
vehicle and following a trail of
possible footprints in the dirt
the Border Patrol agents Union says the
two men were ambushed and attacked with
rocks Texas governor Greg Abbott senator
Ted Cruz and president Donald Trump have
all described what happened as an attack
till we have the facts we shouldn't jump
to those conclusions but congressman
bait or Roarke of El Paso spoke with the
Border Patrol's acting sector chief on
Monday they are following all leads but
at this point they don't know you know
certainly what has happened so where did
the information come from where the
Border Patrol got the information saying
that the agents had been attacked and
they had been attacked with stones we
reached out to the council again last
night and they said they got the
information from agents who were at the
scene the night it happened
we asked the spokesman do you still
stand by the report that the agents were
ambushed and stones were used
we were told quote we stand by it 100%
bianna David our thanks to you